la Journée mondiale de la trisomie 21
c'est le 21 mars prochain mais pas
besoin d'attendre cette date pour parler
handicap et inclusion deux mots qui ont
généralement du mal à coexister au
quotidien des parents se battent pour
que leurs enfants handicapés puissent
vivre comme tout le monde c'est le cas
de François et l'éline de Loiré chérien
atteint de trisomi 21 qui ont tourné le
dos au milieu protégé et à leur foyer
c'est notre dossier de la semaine
réalisé par hélè
chapelet tous les jours de la semaine
dès 7h30 François est à son poste au
rayon bébé 20 ans déjà qu'il travaille
dans cet hypermarché de Vineuil une
ancienneeté remarquable puisque le
quadragén est atteint de trisomi
21 sa mission remplir le rayon et faire
le Fing c'estàdire remettre devant le
stock restant une tâche qu'il prend très
à
[Musique]
cœur
moi
plais
travail c'est autonome c'est bon pour la
tête sur les 340 salariés de
l'hypermarché 21 sont considérés comme
travailleurs handicapés François lui est
présent 24 heures par semaine et pour
que tout se passe bien il faut
comprendre son fonctionnement à chaque
changement de responsable un nouveau
point est organisé entre l'entreprise le
salarié et ses
parents qu'il faut régulièrement répéter
les choses à François pour que ce soit
intégré donc on travaille un petit peu
diff avec lui et on travaille aussi avec
ses parents donc très régulièrement où
on va leur donner des informations sur
le quotidien pour que ses parents
puissent communiquer donc les
informations auprès de François pour
qu'il soit intégré au milieu ordinaire
ses parents ont du batailler ferme car
on ne parlait pas encore d'inclusion il
y a 40 ans un combat rude pour que
François puisse avoir la vie qu'il
voulait et pas celle que les
institutions lui
proposaientit le plus compliqué au jour
d'aujourd'hui c'est l'administration
c'est c'est c'est pas c'est pas
tellement l'employeur c'est c'est pas
tellement le jeune c'est c'est
l'administration où on est dans un
système parallèle dans un monde
parallèle que où on n'est pas dans
l'filer handicap on n'est pas totalement
dans le monde ordinaire mais il y a rien
il y a on coche pas de case elle non
plus ne rentre pas dans les cases l'éine
a 17 ans elle est actuellement en stage
chez Stéphane un traiteur vend au mois
tous les mardis la jeune fille
conditionne les repas vendu en Boco
l'éline c'est lire écrire compter et
faire la cuisine c'est son
rêve la CU avec ces F parce que c'est
pour faire plaisir pour moi pour moi mon
métier j'aimerais faire c'est la cuisine
de la lumière de la saite de la cuisine
pour échanger le regard sur
l'cap quand elle n'est pas derrière les
fourneaux loeline est scolarisée dans un
lycée privé mais elle s'y sent mal les
autres élèves se moquent d'elle
aujourd'hui elle souhaite donc arrêter
son cap une décision que respecte
Stéphane il souhaite d'ailleurs
l'embaucher à temps partiel lui qui a
travaillé pendant 5 ans dans un AAT
milite pour une plus grande intégration
dans le milieu
ordinaire C personnes ont leur place
dans la société elles veulent leur place
pour la plupart c'est il y a beaucoup de
personnes qui sont en structure et qui
demanderaient qu'à en sortir ce qui
pourrait laisser la place à d'autres qu'
en ont vraiment besoin
donc donc du coup voilà autant essayer
de leur donner un peu leur chance selon
la Fédération trisomi 21 France il naît
chaque année 500 enfants porteurs de
cette maladie François et loéine font
partie de ceux que l'on a écouté et qui
ont pu chois le vie une vie comme tout
le monde loin du milieu
protégé